vsauce kevin here and i have a simple
coin flipping game that requires no
skill has no
catch or trick and can lead to infinite
wealth the thing is nobody really wants
to play it
why how is it possible that an
incredibly
easy game with infinite upside causes
virtually
everyone to react with a massive
yawn to play this game we'll turn to the
most rational calculating man
in history long time friend of vsauce2
vsauce dwight schrute
you walk up to the table to flip a coin
your prize starts at two dollars if the
coin flip results in false
the game is over and you win two dollars
if it lands on fact you play another
round and your prize doubles
every time you get a fact you keep
playing and the prize
keeps doubling from two dollars to four
dollars to 8
16 32 64 128
so on and so on forever but as soon as
you get a
false you are done and you collect your
winnings so
if you hit a false in the third round
then your prize is eight dollars
if your false comes in round 14 you'd
walk away with
sixteen thousand three hundred and
eighty four dollars no matter how
unlucky you are you'll never win less
than two dollars if things go really
well then
things go really well now that you know
the potential payoffs how much would you
be willing to pay
to play this game three dollars
what about twenty dollars one hundred
dollars
the winnings could be infinite so the
question is
how much is a chance at infinite wealth
worth to you we can determine the
precise answer but first
we need to know the game's expected
value
which is the sum of all its possible
outcomes relative to their probability
that determines the point at which we
choose to play
a game or in the real world the point at
which we decide to
take out insurance on our house or a
life insurance policy if our risk is
less than our likely reward
we should play if we're paying too much
relative to what we're likely to get out
of playing then we should
not play here's the expected value of
schrute
you've got a 50 50 chance of losing on
your first flip
and heading back to the beat farm with
two bucks with a probability of
one half and a payoff of two dollars
your expected value in the first round
is one dollar
the probability of winning two rounds is
one-half
times one-half or one-fourth and your
prize there would be
four dollars that's another one dollar
in expected value
for three successful flips it's one half
raised to the third power
or one over eight times the eight dollar
prize
another dollar one over sixteen times
sixteen one over 32 times
32 1 over 64 times 64 etc etc etc
for n rounds the expected value is the
probability
1 over 2 to the nth power times the
payoff
of 2 to the nth power so no matter the
value of n
the result will be one the expected
value of the game is one plus one plus
one plus one plus one plus one plus one
plus one plus one well
love
forever because each round adds one
dollar of value
no matter how rare the occurrence might
be
the expected value is infinite
and there's our paradox because
you'd think a rational person would pay
all the money they have to play
this game mathematically it makes sense
to pay
any amount of money less than infinity
to play no matter what amount of money
you
risk you're theoretically getting the
deal of a lifetime
the reward justifies the risk but
nobody wants to do that who would empty
their bank account to play a game where
they know
there's a 75 percent chance that they
walk away with
four dollars or less it's
confusing because expected value is
mathematically how you determine whether
you'll play a game
look if i offered you a coin flipping
game where you won
5 on heads and lost 1
on tails your expected value of each
round would be the sum of those possible
outcomes fifty percent chance times
winning five dollars
plus fifty percent chance times losing
one dollar
half the time you'll win five dollars
and half the time you'll lose
one dollar in the long run you'll
average plus two dollars for every round
you play
so paying anything under two dollars to
play
that game would be a great deal when the
price to play
is less than your expected value it's a
no-brainer
and since the expected value of the
schrute game is
infinite paying anything less than
infinite money to play it
should also be a no-brainer but it's not
why
the thing that's so interesting about
this game is how the math
conflicts with actual humans enter
prospect theory an element of cognitive
psychology in which people make choices
based on the value of wins and losses
instead of just theoretical outcomes
the reason people don't want to empty
their pockets to play this game despite
its infinite gains is that the expected
marginal utility its actual value to
them
goes down as those mathematical gains
increase forever this solution was
discovered a few years ago
a few hundred years ago in 1738 daniel
bernoulli published his
exposition of a new theory on the
measurement of risk
in the commentaries of the imperial
academy of science of saint
petersburg and what we now call the
saint
petersburg paradox was born bernoulli
didn't dispute the expected value of the
saint petersburg game
those are cold hard numbers he just
realized there was a lot more to it
bernoulli introduced the concept of the
expected utility
of a game what was until the 20th
century called
moral expectation to differentiate it
from mathematical expectation
the main point of bernoulli's resolution
was that utility or how much
a thing matters to you is relative to an
individual's wealth
and that each unit tends to be worth
a little less to you as you accumulate
it so as an example not only would
winning
one thousand dollars mean a lot more to
someone who's broke
than it would to say tony stark but even
winning one million dollars wouldn't
affect the research and development at
stark industries
and there's also a limit on a player's
comfort with
risk with john maynard keynes arguing
that a high relative risk
is enough to keep a player from engaging
in a game
even with infinite expected value iron
man can afford to lose a few billion
you probably can't
and value itself is subjective if
i won 1 000 peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
i would be thrilled if someone allergic
to peanuts won them
they would be less thrilled
so okay okay okay okay given all this
how much can you afford to lose in the
saint petersburg
game how badly do you want to play
bernoulli used the logarithmic function
to come up with price points
that factored in not only the expected
value of the game
but also the wealth of the player and
its expected
utility a millionaire should be
comfortable paying as much as 20 dollars
and
88 cents to flip schrutes while someone
with 1 000
would top out at ten dollars and ninety
five cents
someone with a total of two dollars of
wealth should according to the
logarithmic function
borrow a dollar thirty five from a
friend to pay three dollars and thirty
five
cents ultimately everyone has their own
price that factors in their wealth
their desires their comfort with risk
their preferences
how they want to spend their time what
else they could be doing with their
money their
own happiness and
the thing is this game can't even
exist economist paul samuelson points
out that
a game of potentially infinite gain
requires
the other party to be comfortable with
potentially
infinite loss and
no one is cool with that so if the
important
elements are variable and the game can't
exist what's the point
the saint petersburg paradox reminds us
that we're all
more than math the raw numbers might
convince a
robot that it's a good idea to wager its
robo house on a series of coin flips but
you know
deep down that's a really bad idea
because you aren't an expected value
calculation you aren't a logarithmic
function the numbers are a part of you
and help you live your life but in the
end
you are you
[Applause]
fact and as always thanks for watching